hi everybody my name is uh jury
espionage
i'm a fourth year graduate student
at portland state university in the lab
of uh
dr robert m strongen um i
actually used to work for uh high times
magazine i was their science editor
um and after that was after studying uh
getting my bes in chemistry
so i started uh doing uh you know i
joined portland state university
and they had been doing this work with
e-cigarettes for
a fairly long time uh maybe around five
years and before that
they were doing a lot of work with
tobacco and i joined and i said hey why
don't we
extend this project over to the cannabis
vaporizers and so that's why i started
working there
and it's really been a great experience
working with these people here as a lot
of really
really really intelligent uh really
really hard workers here at portland
state and um
we're doing a lot to uncover some of the
chemistry that's going on with
these vaporizers and really i think one
of the strengths
at psu here is that you know we're not
just about
you know quantifying components in here
but we actually look at
the mechanism of how these degradation
products are forming so there's a lot of
really interesting chemistry here for
anyone that's interested
and um so my presentation i'm going to
be talking about
some of these things that we've found
out about the
vaporizing of cannabis cannabis
components
uh that are typically put into
vaporizers or
used for dabbing and so
but i'm also uh because this is sort of
for credits and this is something that
is uh
meant to be a little more educational
maybe than the standard presentation
i am going to be going over some
background on
uh on aerosol science
uh to put it generally and yeah i think
this should be pretty informative for
anyone that's interested in this kind of
emerging field in cannabis
um so a little background on cannabis
botany i would imagine that given the
audience most people aren't
too unfamiliar with uh with what's on
the slide but i'll go over it
the essential oils which are going to
contain the active ingredients cannabis
are located and external structures
called trichomes and you can see a photo
there they're pretty small as you can
see from the animation they zoom into a
cannabis bud these little tiny
structures that contain the oils and
these are going to be what contains the
thc
the tetrahydrocannabinol the active
ingredient or cannabidiol cbd
another active ingredient and other
cannabinoids as well and also the
terpenes are going to be located
in these uh in these trichomes as well
all other parts of the the anatomy of
the plant contain around three percent
cannabinoids
or cannabis plants that actually produce
a lot of terpenes
uh and so really it's on the outside so
what people do is they take these
these buds dry buds or fresh
freshly harvested buds just the flowers
mostly and they put them into containers
stainless steel what have you
they pass solvents over them these can
be butane
supracritical carbon dioxide and these
are solvents that are nonpolar
because the active ingredients the
essential oils are
also not polar so like dissolves like so
you have your butane here
superglutable carbon dioxide is a
non-polar solvent it actually has a
polarity roughly around that of hexane
it's also used to decaffeinate
coffee you know it's one of the ways
that people eat caffeinate coffee
and what people have been doing maybe in
the last five years or so it's getting
really popular is people take
these this kind of crude extract they
use fractional distillation vacuum
vacuum distillation separate out the
cannabinoids from
and the terpenes from kind of everything
else maybe waxes and lipids that are
also in there
and then they can recombine these things
or they can take
uh terpenes derived from other
uh sources and combine them into thc and
put them in vape pens for example right
so i'm going to go over
some of these what some of these
components are now
uh you can see these the set of
structures on on the right here uh
pardon i can't really point to anything
so just going to bear with me a little
bit
uh cannabinoids start off in what's
called their acid form so you can see up
there cbda
and thca delta 9 thc that delta 9 for
anyone that's curious refers to the
placement of the double bond
on the upper
left hand most ring up there
and so delta eight thc is when that bond
flops over one space to the left and
then there's
there's other ones as well much less
common
uh delta nine that placement of the
double bond there is the most common one
and that that's that's what the plant
actually makes you know the biosynthetic
pathways in the plant actually makes
dhca delta nine and cbd a
and so these things these
acid cannabinoids as they're called are
not directly active
and studies like for example i could
think of maybe one where these are
injected into a mouse and at the
bloodstream they don't really do
anything
um or if you were to orally ingest
thca you wouldn't get high
uh because that that thca not only does
it get broken down by the liver
pretty extensively more than thc but it
also i don't think it crosses the
blood-brain barrier
it's just not it's not psychoactive
right and so through a process called
decarboxylation
that acid group on the ring is lost
so this de-carbing as it's called
colloquially
is something that's done to make edibles
and it's also something that happens as
you might imagine when you vaporize or
smoke
cannabis that contains thca and that
active thc that can now cross the
blood-brain barrier
is going to be what causes that
psychoactive effect
likewise this also happens with cvda
when you heat it turns into cbd and you
can see here the way i set up these
arrows
the arrows that are pointing down are
uh you have the h nu
or like that new is a greek letter kind
of looks like a v
that it that refers to uh light
ultraviolet light
energy is going to hit those molecules
when the plant's growing or on storage
and you're going to have that double
bond isomerization now that's where you
have the
the delta eight there you see that
double bond move from from on that right
portion to the left portion now right
and then you can have more
photons come in from light and they can
actually cyclize that ring now that ring
there is now aromatic
it's that's an oxidation when you lose
hydrogens that's an oxidation just like
when you gain oxygen that's also an
oxidation right
and then now that whole set of
structures on the left
with a big bracket pointing to the
structures on the right
i have a delta there delta that's the
symbol which refers to
adding heat and you can see a co2 carbon
dioxide popping off so all of those
acid-containing molecules can get
decarboxylated and so yes you can have
cbna
that's the acid form of cbn
cbn being cannabinol which is on the
right on the bottom right there right
the cbn's becoming other just lately so
those are all the cannabinoids uh people
talk about thcv
and they talk about cbgv and they talk
about all these other things
those are all kind of nice that
naturally the plant doesn't really make
a lot of
uh it's just not um not genetically
controlled
so all the plants all the cannabis
plants in the world they either make
cbd thc or both
and then you have some kind of anomalies
that'll make more of one and obviously
selective breeding can make it so you
have plants that produce
more and more of just the minor
cannabinoids so but those are the big
ones
and then when it comes to the terpenes
uh everyone talks about you know there's
all these terpenes in cannabis and there
are there's
hundreds well maybe more around 68.
there was one study that said this one
68.
but there's four or five i've
highlighted four over here that are the
major
terpenes and those are going to be the
dominant ones
that are going to be in the essential
oils right
so because we're talking about
how cannabis aerosolizes i'm going to go
over some sort of
sort of basic uh aerosol science
uh physics that uh deals with
a really interesting phenomena called
gas particle partitioning that sounds
like a mouthful but
it's it's pretty intuitive when you
think about it um
in aerosol just to define
is composed of the particulate phase
gas phase articulate phase are very very
tiny droplets
and the gas phases gases that surround
these droplets so when you look at a
cloud
cloud in the sky or a cloud of smoke or
vapor
you see the cloud it's visible to you
because of the droplets now those
droplets
are going to diffract light and they're
going to bounce it around
and so you can see them they're visible
gases are going to surround that
and components of that particulate phase
are going to evaporate into the gas
phase and you have components of the gas
phase that are going to
going to condense into the particular
phase and so there's there's an
equilibrium between the particle phase
of the aerosol
and the gas phase of the aerosol
different components
you could imagine the more volatile ones
are going to be more present in the gas
phase and other components are going to
be present in the
particle phase of the aerosol and so
there's a set of equations here
that are going to sort of govern this by
a really important one
is the partition coefficient that was
developed by
someone that a principal investigator
here at portland state
that i work with and he's actually on my
thesis committee uh
dr james f penkow so this partition
coefficient is
really kind of a consequence of henry's
law of of uh
you know that deals with vapor pressures
right and so
when you have components that are
volatile they're going to be
gases they're going to want to be in the
gas phase and components that are not
volatile they're going to be in the
particle phase
and you can see that kp the partition
coefficient is
cp that's the concentration of the
component in the particle phase
divided by cg concentration of the
component in the gas phase
and you can see that is inversely
proportional to
the vapor pressure so when you have a
high vapor pressure
then the component will want to be in
the gas phase it's pretty intuitive
and we can use that those two set of
formulas that are just below that
to calculate just the fraction the
percentage uh
of what percentage something is going to
be in the gas phase
or the particle phase so
you know what's the consequence of this
well the the aerosol
from vaping cannabis is going to have
uh some a lot of components and i don't
want to say
an extremely large amount of components
compared to like cannabis smoke which
you can have
anymore but the the aerosol from vaping
cannabis is going to have
for example if you have a vape pen that
has like 90 thc
and 10 terpenes that aerosol is going to
be
like 90 just those components right
the thc because it is a very low vapor
pressure
is going to be entirely in the particle
phase of the aerosol
you see in my table here i've arranged
some components of the aerosol
by vapor pressure so at the top you have
the components with the lowest vapor
pressure and at the bottom
the components the highest vapor
pressure and you can see that the
percentages in the gas phase
increase right so the cbd and thc are
going to be entirely in the particle
phase with zero percent in a gas phase
and then terpenes are going to slowly
increase
in vapor pressure and they're going to
is more and more
you're going to have a higher and higher
percentage of them in the
in the gas phase right so linoleum which
actually has an oh on it
maybe i can go back to this slide little
has an oh on it so it's going to
hydrogen bond
it's going to be a molecule that is
going to have a lower vapor pressure
than for example mercy right so
little o is going to have a higher
percentage of it is going to be in the
particle phase it's only 5.3 percent of
the gas phase
whereas pinene for example is 57 of it
is going to be in a gas phase
so you're going to smell those things
right and then these degradation
products toluene methyl vinyl ketone
benzene with acrylin
going to be almost entirely in the gas
phase because they're pretty volatile
bottled molecules and for anyone that
wants to go back and look at these
slides i just
the water and the acetone lines that i
gave in there just reference
reference vapor pressures they're pretty
commonly available
things right so you can you can look at
that for comparison
now the there's some pretty interesting
implications in
well in in health there's pretty
interesting implications of this
because uh well
i'll start with the particle phase of
near so the particle phase of the
aerosols
are going to deposit in the lungs so
when you inhale a thc containing aerosol
thc is completely in the particles that
you can little droplets
you're going to get in the lungs and
that's how that stuff gets in your
bloodstream right
but gases are going to
deposit in the respiratory tract
and it's going to depend on how soluble
in water they are right so
you know because the lining of your
respiratory tract is aqueous is you know
the bronchial epithelium there right so
for example methyl vinyl ketone
is has a lower henry's constant
that's something that's going to relate
to water solubility it's a lower
henry's constant than example toluene so
that stuff is going to deposit
the upper respiratory tract and so it's
going to irritate the throat
and the upper respiratory tract the
sacral and
that's something we identified but the
benzene and toluene they're going to be
lower right
so these are some of the things that are
implicated in like the harshness of the
vaporizer and smoking as well right
so i want to now talk about some of the
experiments that i started doing when i
joined portland
state here so this is something uh from
a paper that we published in 217
you can see it's pretty interesting
experimental setup here there's a little
a little dab rig that's called a water
pipe with a nail ceramic nail on it
and we have a coal trap and an impinger
with nmr solvent so that we do a dab but
and at this point we're just working
with terpenes because we didn't have a
dea license yet
and so we just measured some degradation
products here i'm gonna talk
too much about this stuff because we we
built on this a lot so i'll talk about
more
about that stuff right uh but i do want
to point out that we were able to really
accurately measure the temperature of
the nail so we
had some interesting temperature
dependent things here
it we heated the nail up to really hot
and let it cool down and then did the
dab at the temperature that we wanted
to so we weren't doing dabs at 590
celsius that was just
sort of a reference temperature there
and as you might have seen this
this paper we posted in this journal acs
omega part of the
chemical society and it is the most
viewed paper
in that journal is 60 almost 63 000
views so
it made a big splash in the in the
dabbing
cannabis world right and
we most notably we found some really
interesting chemistry with the terpenes
and what we found is that
sort of unsurprisingly terpenes all
react
in in a similar manner to each other and
all the terpene
well those three terpenes that we
studied the linoleum limonene and mercy
and we studied caryophylline as well
they all react to form sort of large
amounts of isoprene
you know if you're familiar with uh some
ocam uh
turbines are made up of ice spring units
that's kind of what defines them
so when these things react they're going
to make a lot of isoprene
and isoprene itself we theorize
what would go on to make other these
other degradation products
i'll explain that more in a second and
thc
you see that red highlighted part there
that
should look pretty similar to you to
laminator right it's because thc is a
terpenophenolic molecule
it has a terpene part to it and a
phenolic part the phenolic part is that
benzene ring with the oh sticking off of
it
so we theorized that thc might make very
similar degradation products
to terpenes and so we had to wait to get
our dna license we got it we started
studying thc but
i want to talk more just briefly about
that isoprene oxidation
because we we looked into the literature
and said well
you know how is ice cream going to react
and what we found is that
uh in the field of atmospheric chemistry
this is actually a pretty well studied
set of reactions uh because these are
isoprene is going to be released in
forests right and so
that ice cream gets up in the atmosphere
and it's going to react with oxygen in
the air it's going to make this
this slew of degradation products which
is very similar
to the degradation products that we
observed from dabbing
terpenes and thc and
this is an interesting implication here
just for another side note
is that there's this uh this study that
was published i'd really recommend
checking this paper out it's open access
everyone wants to check it out
uh done by some well one of the people
on that paper is a collaborator of ours
they looked at the air quality in
cannabis grow rooms outside and in
and so there's a lot of really
interesting interesting details there
one of the major takeaways is that the
high the better the ventilation was the
better the air quality so that's
something you want to keep in mind
because that stuff all those volatile
organics just like the terp beans are
going to actually make ozone and that
might not be good either for
for anyone inhaling it but it also could
degrade
can further oxidize some some components
of
whatever you have in there right so um
yeah so when we got thc in the lab
we we wanted to study this as the best
method that we could
and so one of our collaborators here had
this really interesting
experimental setup called uh automate
adsorption thermal desorption
uh gasoline concrete mass spectrometry
so what this is is
is gcms whoever's if you're familiar
with that already this is a sampling
method for that
that allows you to just basically
collect gases
onto this little tube that you can see
there the atd cartridge that a little
cartridge full of absorbent material
gases get stuck to that
and then a machine is going to
desorb them and they're going to go
right into
uh the gcms essentially and so
that that that atd cartridge can only
handle
gases and so
you need to filter the aerosol of our of
all the particulates and so that
that on this picture here where it says
cfp
holder that's a special specialized
filter called the cambridge filter pad
it's in that holder is going to filter
out the particulates the aerosol right
and so what's interesting then is that
when we see
a chromatogram from dabbing thc
we don't see any thc in here because
this is just
the gases of the aerosol no particulates
so this is just
a way of looking at the degradation
products and so at the
at the lower retention times we see some
c4 to c5
components is acetone there's aline and
a lot of ice brain
unsurprisingly because of how thc is a
turbine
and then we start to see c6 and c7 as we
go up in retention times
we see toluene we see benzene
methacrylan methyl vinyl ketone
cotanaldehyde butanol those are nasty
things you don't want to be inhaling and
there's all these alkanes in there
that toxicologically are not too
relevant but they could be sensitizers
and then at higher retention times you
start to see less and less but
you do see some xylenes uh and
and other c10 components now that's just
from dabbing
thc but remember now terpenes
are going to be heavily present in the
gas phase of the aerosol
and so those large peaks in the green
portion there at around 20 those are
terpenes right so when you dab thc and
terpenes those terpenes are going to get
in the gas phase and you're going to see
them in this chromatogram
and we were able to quantify some of
these degradation products that were
present in the aerosol
we have uh ethacryl and benzene toluene
these are all things we made a
calibration curve for
and you see here at the top you see
uh the thc dab and mock distillate that
mock distillate was
we we purchased uh analytical grade thc
and we added terpenes to it
to make what we call mocht island this
was 90 thc in 10
terpenes and you can see there's a
really significant increase
between from just having thc
to dabbing thc and terpenes a bit large
increase in the degradation products
th terpenes are going to be much more
thermally labeled
which means much more prone to
degradation than just thcs they're
smaller molecules that
they absorb a little bit of energy and
they're just going to start breaking
apart with thcs larger molecules kind of
take more energy to break it apart but
thc still makes and then we also vape
them
we also vape this mixture this ninety
percent thc 10 percent terpenes mixture
put it in a standard like a c cell
cartridge and we vaped it at three
different voltages
and you can see there that as you
increase the
voltage that's an increase in energy
applied to the distillate and
that that's we observed large amounts of
degradation products
so these are pretty uh nasty things here
so i
would encourage everyone to check out
that paper and
to to sort of consider you know what it
is they put in a vape pen we're gonna
have some more results about
some of these components uh for example
mct oil and
other things that people are putting in
there we're gonna study that and
yeah we encourage everyone to really
think about you know what it is they're
they're vaping definitely the more
terpenes you put in there
likely is more degradation products that
are going to be in there because a lot
of people actually say that oh if you
decrease the viscosity of your oil then
that's going to lead to less degradation
well the terpenes
degrade much more easily so it's it's
probably not a good idea
especially and for really anyone that's
that's
that's vaping is going to be exposed to
this so people are more sensitive to
these components
they might want to watch out obviously
uh you know we started talking about
this stuff before
the holy poly outbreak this is the work
that we did
around a year ago and and we published
it right in the middle of the valley
outbreak
and so everything changed after that
but um you know it's still it's still
hold it's it's getting much more
interesting now with all these
developments about the other additives
people are using so that is something
we're going to study
as as time goes on so i want to thank
the national institute of health and the
fda for funding
uh and portland state university also
for funding the drug enforcement agency
helped us with us the security
requirements necessary for us to
legally study schedule one
cannabis in a lab because our lab is
fairly funded so we need to have
we obey through a loss and the pancal
lab
dr wentei luo and kevin porter for
helping us out with the atd
gcms collection methods and my research
assistant
alicia ortiz and obviously my my
principal investigator my pi uh dr
robert strongan
all right thank